du troisième prix poésie ligne des
collégiens pour son premier recueil la
maison morphelie la maison morcelée en
fait c'est
métaphore de la mémoire donc ma
grand-mère elle est décédée de
l'Alzheimer et je trouvais que justement
parler de cette maison d'enfance la
perte de l'enfance la perte de la
mémoire
lycéenne à Trappes étudiante à
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'auteur y
recevait hier sa distinction avec
émotion
comme le poème est un électron libre une
particule devant une poussière de
lumière son livre était en lice aux
côtés de 4 autres recueil de poésie j'ai
préféré
je sens en plus énergies dedans que les
autres professionnels étaient un peu
plus tristes et la maison morcelée était
bien mais comment dire elle était un
petit peu triste parce que vu la perte
la paire de sa grand-mère ça m'a un peu
touché aussi les collégiens ils montent
eux ont apprécié son niveau de langue
accessible les figures de style
évocatrices et le détail des décors de
la maison d'enfance
la fin du roman était mouvante pleine de
nostalgie et de tendresse c'est une
véritable écriture qui est en train
d'émerger là surtout sur cette forme de
prose courte qu'elle a utilisé moins
peut-être dans la prose longue qui
termine le livre et il y a cette gravité
peut-être chez Lydia et puis ce côté un
peu fantastique presque dans sa manière
de de percevoir cette maison qui a fait
que ce livre a retenu l'attention
peut-être aussi une unité dans le ton
donc
la terre du géranium blanc se soulève
sous le poids des ongles l'engrais salée
l'engraisse pas la plante ni le souvenir